[BLANK_AUDIO]
Something significant to
Miwoks would be acorns.
What I've learned is that going to
these annual celebrations the big time.
Acorns are life.
That's where food comes from.
And just the celebration around it.
It's a gathering of people.
It's grinding them, it's leaching them.
The baskets, the basket weaving.
There are baskets that are made for
leaching.
There are baskets made for
gathering, storing.
So to me I would say acorns
would be a big significant
item to the Miwok people.
So around the region where Miwok are,
there are the black oak acorns.
And they just have a sweeter taste when
you leech out the tannins, soak them.
They're, they have a sweeter taste than
I don't want to say a regular oak tree,
but a different type of tree that is
more bitter, it's a bitter taste.
You can make soups, bread,
one of the interviews
that I did with my grandmother,
and I had no idea about this.
We had a whole plot of land up in Iowa,
and
my great grandmother would go out into
the backyard, and she would dig a hole
and line it with cheesecloth, and
she would leach acorns in our backyard.
She would make soups,
she would make bread.
I think she would even make
tortillas out of them.
And acorn mush.
But yeah,
that was something that I never knew and
my grandma shared with you one day,
and it's like,
I would never have known that just
in the backyard where I grew up.
[LAUGH] There were leaching of acorns.